I gotta juice up a little bit you never
know who you might write you
[Music]
it's been a few weeks since I last saw
Tom I blocked Tom I need to talk to him
I don't hear from him just gotta move on
ready Neal are you ready oh I've been
ready oh all right I'm just trying to
get my life back on track and use this
time to love myself better myself and I
just want to focus on me again
so do you think Tom's still with that
woman
oh the blonds yeah who knows
even if he's that doesn't matter now I'm
not gonna be played for a fool you know
I gave my heart and I tried my best but
I just like you can only do it for so
long you know I deserve better and you
try to reach out to me again I left town
behind but a few days ago I got a
message and I don't recognize the number
but the guy identified himself as a good
friend of Tom's from the UK he basically
was like I'm a friend of Tom's we've
known each other over 20 years and
Nottingham from my conversations with
Tom he told me that he had made a
mistake and wanted to see if I could
bridge the conversation between you two
I know he would love that
please let me know what you think did
not respond I'll find someone else I
don't
I didn't reply to his friend and
basically a few hours later I got a
similar message from his mom
I didn't reply I don't want to reply he
could send all the messages through
other people if he wants but no one's
gonna get a response back I am done I
meant it and I mean it
[Music]